on july 4th 1776 56 founding fathers
came together and they produced the
declaration of independence
the 13 states at the time had been at
war with the kingdom of great britain
for about a year and it was finally the
moment where these 56 founding fathers
and their 13 states announced their own
sovereignty they no longer were going to
put up with the onerous rule of the
kingdom of great britain if we take a
look at the declaration of independence
what we can see is that bitcoin is
essentially the modern day declaration
of independence now let's first take a
look at the existing document to
understand how bitcoin overlays with it
first you have the introduction and in
the introduction there's an assertion
that natural law gives the ability of
people to assume political independence
they specifically state that it becomes
necessary for one person to dissolve the
political bands which have connected
them with another and to assume among
the powers of the earth the separate and
equal station to which the laws of
nature and the nature's god entitle them
a decent respect to the opinions of
mankind requires that they should
declare the causes which impel them to
the separation
and then in the preamble we get the meat
of the argument which is that the
founding fathers hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal that they are endowed by their
creator with certain unalienable rights
that among these are life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness and that to
secure these rights governments are
instituted among men deriving their just
powers from the consent of the governed
that whenever any form of government
becomes destructive of these ends it is
the right of the people to alter or to
abolish it and to institute new
government laying its foundation on such
principles and organizing its powers in
such form as to them shall seem most
likely to affect their safety and
happiness
and then the founding fathers went on to
a section of indictment and they lay out
point by point all of their grievances
with the kingdom of great britain
in it they hold back no punches they
simply state over and over again this is
what you have done and this is why we
can no longer take it lastly those 56
founding fathers come together and they
issue this conclusion
we therefore the representatives of the
united states of america in general
congress assembled appealing to the
supreme judge of the world doing the
name and by authority of the good people
of these colonies solemnly publish and
declare that these united colonies are
and of right ought to be free and
independent states that they are
absolved from all allegiance to the
british crown and that all political
connection between them and the state of
great britain is and ought to be totally
dissolved
and then as free and independent states
they have full power to levy war
conclude peace contract alliances
establish commerce and to do all other
acts and things which independent states
may of right do
and for the support of this declaration
with a firm reliance on the protection
of divine providence we mutually pledge
to each other our lives our fortunes and
our sacred honor now of course when i
make the claim that bitcoin is the
modern day declaration of independence
you have to understand what the
declaration of independence was doing
bitcoin is a database of code and it
allows for any person to opt in to new
monetary sovereignty
what it means is if you don't consent to
the previous regime of governance where
a central bank can debase your currency
unilaterally without your agreement
there's a lot of people who think that
bitcoin is the peaceful resistance to
that lack of true agreeable governance
and so naturally bitcoin when it was
launched on january 3rd 2009 marked the
start of a new monetary regime it has a
programmatic monetary policy it's
transparently presented for anyone to
audit at any time if you are an
individual anywhere in the world
regardless of sex creed gender wealth or
status
you can opt in to a brand new monetary
regime you don't have to do it with 100
of your economic value but you now have
a path that allows you to conduct
some sort of protection of your own
assets
the united states of america and the
private property rights of its citizens
makes it one of the greatest countries
in the world
now bitcoin is exporting these american
ethos to people around the world and
allowing them to have actual private
property of their monetary assets
allowing them to peacefully resist
against the debasement of their currency
we are living in a time of historic
inflation both in the united states of
america and other countries around the
globe and in each one of these regions
previously people either had to become
investors or they simply had to have
their economic value and their wealth
debased the way
today
bitcoin provides a different path it
allows for anyone to opt in and to
participate in a brand new declaration
of independence
bitcoin is a technological solution that
exports the american ethos to billions
of humans globally
ultimately bitcoin and the launch of
this asset going all the way back to
january 3rd 2009
when it's all said and done hundreds of
years from now i think people will look
back and they will say that bitcoin was
the modern day declaration of
independence
not independence from governments not
independents from other rulers
simply monetary independence that
allowed people to return to a life of
simply saving spending less than they
make and being able to choose
some level of economic freedom as the
declaration of independence back in july
4th of 1776 promised
every human should have the right to
pursue life liberty and happiness
bitcoin is helping to return a little
bit of that dream to billions and
billions of people and every single
individual of the hundred plus million
who have adopted this asset
slowly but surely begin to realize
they come for the money but they stay
for the money and if we can fix the
money
a lot of people who think that we can
fix the world